j'ai un peu de réticence à donner de la
visibilité à tous ces fascistes au petit
pied qui postent des vidéos je pense
qu'il faut pas trop en faire non plus
parce que c'est n'attendent que ça
évidemment la vidéo est abject
évidemment il faut l'espérer qui est des
plaintes qui ont placé mais on espère
que la justice sanctionnera mais
aujourd'hui je le répète il n'y a pas de
base juridique qui permette à faro ce
sens une procédure judiciaire qui prend
du temps de faire en sorte de retirer
ces vidéos si on veut faire en sorte que
les obligations de moyens
c'est ce que doit nous permettre la loi
comporte en est d'accord pour l'instant
en tout cas du gouverneur du côté
gouvernement pas de réactions politiques
à cette vidéo qui met en cause ou qui
visent des militants de la france a
soumises
pas de réaction donc je pense qu'il faut
être extrêmement clair
d'abord cette vidéo est abject ensuite
elle est et doit être condamné par
toutes les forces politiques y compris
d'ailleurs le rassemblement national y
compris par le gouvernement donc il
compris par le gouvernement je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que
le gouvernement à la fois qu'on d'armes
et espère que les auteurs de cette vidéo
seront condamnés par la justice
[Musique]